bang-bang
[Music]
you know it it's that old familiar thing
it's that screen door on that front
porch you know where you are brother you
know where you are sister you're home
oh man thank you guys for being here
with me today happy Monday morning to
you and it is Monday and it is February
5 in the year 201 8 and we are here in
the in outer space can you believe that
we're in outer space right now and
everybody's always talking about you
know meet me at the mall or you know GPS
dude we are in outer space
we are astronauts you realize that we
are astronauts right now so if you meet
somebody and they seem like they might
be a little bit foreign they might be an
alien and I'm not talking about illegal
alien or Illya I'm gonna talk anything
about anything like that I'm talking
about if you meet somebody and they got
this crazy look in their eyes and they
seem like something wild is going on
like they're picking their nose but from
the inside of their body without even
using their fingers if they seem geeked
up like the universe is just you know
just just just just tickling a feather
against the back of their brainstem then
maybe they're an alien I mean it's not
that far-fetched to think that there
could be aliens amongst us why because
we live in outer space guys
that's why and if you were an alien and
you came here would you tell everybody
would you tell everybody you're an alien
probably not
you know you probably wouldn't that's
the first you know right there I caught
it you probably wouldn't tell anybody
you're an alien or at least in the past
you wouldn't I think these days now now
you might tell people oh yeah I am an
alien because now it's like it's like
the me generation you know now you'd be
at a party and you'd have you know a
couple gin and tonics and next thing you
know you're over in the you know you're
over in the corner showing you know
showing a one of your neighbors your
freaking tentacle dick or whatever you
know or showing your you know how your
nipples can light up you know you'd be
so there's it now I think if we're gonna
know if there are aliens amongst us we
will know it soon because I don't think
that people can keep secrets as well as
they used to and maybe that's just me
being you know a little bit outlandish
but I believe that I don't I don't think
we can keep secrets as well as we used
to it's not a lot of sacred 'ti anymore
you know things aren't as sacred and I
know secret doesn't then go to sacred I
know that's not how it go you know I
know that those two words aren't
connected but in a way they they are
it's you know there's a lot of Secrets
anymore everything's out there you know
all the information it's all out there
you know and they say knowledge is power
and I think it is but I also think some
of it's just you can go on with them
facts jack won't you put your facts back
in a bag and going back down this
mountain because we don't want all that
around here and I'm not saying that I
don't want to be informed I just want to
say at a certain point for me where
information starts to beat down on my
imagination you know where I can't even
you know we're imagining is even as fun
adios amigos or adios amigo so if you're
listening to them rap boys because
that's where I'm at Super Bowl is on
Iran in a five met Gerard Butler got to
talk to him the other night at the
Comedy Store so you know sometimes
things are planned sometimes God have
plans or a higher power have plans for
you
and that's what happened cuz I know in
the past I planned on meeting on the
meet and draw Butler and then I didn't
get to meet him and and here he was BAM
him and his buddy his boy Freddie and
they popped out and said what's up to
you boy and we chatted for a while it
was a good conversation we're gonna talk
about the Super Bowl here's what here's
what I'm doing I just watch the first
quarter and then I decided I'm gonna
start podcasting and for me man out the
gate this bowl wasn't as I wasn't
feeling this into this Super Bowl I
don't know if anybody else felt that way
it didn't feel but it didn't feel like
the Super Bowl to me you know I'm
sitting there and I'm like man this is a
Super Bowl this is it just didn't feel
super it felt like a regular Bowl and
that's kind of the vibe that I got it
felt like a regular Bowl to me how's it
going this this it felt like a regular
game and I don't know first I wondered
well maybe we're so used to things
happening so fast now that the two-week
delay between the championship NFC and
AFC Championship and the actual Super
Bowl that that's gotten to the point
where it's too long that was one of my
first thoughts like you know because
there comes a time like there's a lot
there's a there's a point where
everything jumps the shark you know like
those beats by dre headphones remember
those three years ago with the bit the
wide headphones they're similar to the
one there's they're similar they're
similar to the ones that I have on in
the youtubes they're similar to the ones
that I have on the youtube if you can
see the YouTube you know these beats by
dre but they were the big headphones
right they were the coolest thing and
then about three or four months ago I
looked at somebody with them on and I
was like that those are done that's
those are over you start seeing things
like that like those that's not a thing
anymore
those are over and that and that's just
part of with the the how culture is it
evolves you know and suddenly if
something's over and I just felt like
that like maybe that's the thing like
maybe this two weeks is just too long
you got too many other things that can
happen and we our attention spans have
gotten so
that two weeks is just not now also I
could have still been butthurt because
my Saints my New Orleans Saints gave up
one of the greatest plays in in American
history and probably in world history to
the Minnesota Vikings and that's what
happened but I stopped it at the first
quarter and I decided to come in podcast
so I got to change the the batteries in
my headphones right now well we got a
good cast man we had you know we had
that gentleman called in last week
Mickey on Thursday's episode we had
sweet Mickey called in and he's
terminally ill you know he's get he got
he have two bad lungs in his body and
the Lord of the devil or somebody gave
him some bad lungs and that's not up to
us we don't we didn't do it but he's got
him you know he's got him and so we had
a lot of callers call in and have
suggestions for him and so we're gonna
get into some of that in a little bit
not yet not yet man I want to tell you
guys about meeting sweet Gerrard so I
met sweet Gerard Butler and then I'll
say this you know I'm a heterosexual
adult you know and I would say if he
chopped me open and divided up and
divided me up into a hundred pieces I
would say probably 97 of those pieces
would be heterosexual and three percent
of those pieces might be getting wild
you know
being naughty you know what I'm saying
peaking around the roller rink seeing
who might have a little bit of bulge and
they in their forefront and their
trousers but that doesn't mean I would
try anything wow that just means I might
have that double vision that doesn't
mean I want to do anything sexual it
just might see it might be that I see a
man's tricep you know in a distance and
say dang oh he armed up you know you
know I'm saying he armed up and so
that's just all it is you know he could
get out of a pool easy without using the
ladder you know what I'm saying cuz he
that boy tried up he he got them T steps
them
tricera steps and he out the pool like
that without even using the ladders
just like a damn seal you know just like
a dam just like an otter that's trying
to get risque and get out of the pool
and take his chances sipping on air you
know and I don't even know if hotter is
just if they sip on water and I or
breathe water some animals breathe water
breathe breathe water but anyhow uh but
I'm just saying so that's where I'm at
inside of myself you know now who knows
you know when I get older 70 80 I might
be out there you know I'm saying I might
be out there gumming down on some
straight-up Street Wiener or whatever or
local it doesn't matter all I'm saying
is it doesn't matter okay but I'm saying
I saw Gerard Butler and the man have
beautiful eyes okay he has first of all
he could have one eye and be and you
wouldn't even notice
that's how handsome the dude is he could
have cuz every time you see a one eye
dude you're like boom you know you try
to pretend like they don't have one eye
but they have one eye and it's hard you
like do I look like because it's not the
normal usually when you look into
somebody's eyes your eyes kind of zoom
in with theirs and y'all are eyed up i -
i they call it it's an old saying but
now when you catch somebody and they got
that patch and they patched up your eyes
don't know what to do and then your eyes
start getting all crazy and you're like
do I look at their do I look their do I
look their do I look there it's kind of
like no whammies no whammies and it's uh
but Gerard Butler I'm just saying this
two men have two beautiful eyes
beautiful eyes dude and you're thinking
yeah whatever I've seen blue eyes dude
his eyes I'm telling you this man I'm
telling you this from a straight man for
the most part until I'm 70 or 80 when I
might get out there and meet a man but
you don't know but I don't know that and
you don't know that and it's okay if I
do or if you do if you get out there and
meet a man when you older after you've
already had a wife and had a family you
know I'm saying you've done your due
diligence you've done your job as a
father and as a husband and if you get
out and about you know and you out there
skeet
with some you know fellow at the Senior
Center or whatever that's whatever you
want but what I'm saying is this that
Gerard Butler he could have an eyepatch
on you wouldn't even notice
that's how handsome the dude is right he
probably is the dude is 100% handsome a
hundred percent handsome and and he was
cool as could be man he came out his
buddy came out we started chatting we
swapped information he said he was a fan
he'd see me about six weeks ago or
whatever right before I was on the
fighter in the kid podcast I went in and
that's when I saw Gerard Butler Atlas at
the Comedy Store and they're like Gerard
Butler's in the back of the room and I
was a little bit nervous but then I just
you know I'm saying I'll let out because
on stage and I'm trying not to be about
my nerves anymore it's time to shine you
know it's time to shine but then he came
out man we chatted on the front porch
for a while it was cool and and then it
was Pauly Shores birthday last week it
was the same night and Pauly Shore man
he turned 50 you know beautiful man
Pauly Shore and they had a lot of
deviant uh just they had a wild a lot of
wild human animals out at this party and
they had a lot of porn stars and you
know people with them fancy crotches and
you know vulvas that can juggle and all
of that that all them girls out there
with them juggling vulvas and all of
that and everybody was out there and
that was at the comedy store and they
had a band and some girls on stage
singing horrible karaoke this girl was
so bad and people were like oh my god
what's this girl doing up there and then
I heard some other girls say oh it's
probably just some gal that blew Pauly
for some stage time and that made me
laugh because the truth is it probably
was and it was a great time man and it
was nice to see
I mean Pauly Shore grew up in the Comedy
Store can you a Matt dude if I'm there
for three or four hours man you could
get anything you want at the Comedy
Store
you could get joy you could get pain you
could start a family you could buy you
you know I'm saying you could gram up if
you need a couple grams that is sorry
and I'm not naming chemicals so if
you're thinking of something then you
can think about what you want but it's
that kind of place you know it's that
forbidden kitten and you go there and
you put both your hands out and you pet
that plus a you film me cuz that's the
kind of place it is it's that forbidden
it's that forbidden kitten and whenever
you're forbidden kitten is you can get
out there at the Comedy Store and you
can catch that cat because that's the
kind of place it is but good to be here
man I made some myself some coffee dude
I went to the UH you know right by my
place over here I live in Los Angeles
and right by my place over here in Los
Angeles they have a graveyard where
Marilyn Monroe is buried and now Hugh
Hefner's finally in the wall next to her
and that had been like um I think he
bought her a gravesite a long time ago
or something and they plan to be buried
right next to each other and I've been
there a bunch you know probably about 10
times over my existence here in Los
Angeles and finally I get over there and
both of them are they were both you know
shelved in the Wallace had mausoleum
style and both of them are shelved up in
the wall and it's pretty cool
yeah I'm wonderful in the future like
whenever they have grapes like if you go
to a cemetery if they'll just have like
a thing where you rub your phone over it
and it shows you who it is
and a video maybe even that they get to
leave that'd be wild huh I think about
that kind of stuff sometimes you know
about the future you know I used to
think a lot about East have a lot of
visions and stuff about things that
could happen like when I was young I
used to think that at one point they
would have a disc or something you would
put in your car but but the band they
would have a hologram of the actual
artist whatever a musician it was and
the artists would perform on your
dashboard so while you were driving they
would have these Holograms performing
you know it could be anybody it could be
damned you know Kris Kross it could be
you know gerald levert haulin oats Lyle
Lovett it could be anything sting Steven
Seagal it could be anybody performing on
your - were nice to have ideas of that
and visions of that but yeah man I met
Gerard Butler he was beautiful
and he was cool man you know and I'm not
saying I'm trying to wind up on Gerard
I'm not trying to be like that and they
call him Jerry one of his buddies called
him Jerry my damn brother
that's Jerry that's too why
Jerry right there I mean this guy had
portals to the nethersphere he could be
an alien
dror Butler could be an alien you know
when it's like are there aliens out
there a lot of questions already in the
air guys are there aliens out there you
know do Gerard Butler need two eyes dude
us sure I'm just telling you man I'm not
trying to be wild you know when I was
growing up I had a friend that he had
nice blue eyes and I was was jealous
because look let's be honest blue eyed
people are doing well you don't see a
homeless dude with blue eyes you
know I'm saying you'll see some out
there dude out there you know
jiaying out behind the Shoney's you know
some guys selfs keating in a van out
there by himself out there outside of a
widespread panic concert you know all
hopped up on ecstasy or something and
oh damn grilled cheese sandwich
in a van one of those vans with a ladder
on it where's the ladder go what the
talk about hooking a ridiculous
accoutrement to something hey here's a
van how can we make it look cooler let's
put a ladder on the side of it
guess what you go up the ladder you're
on top of a van you idiot why don't we
hook why don't we hook uh why don't we
hook a a water purifier on the side
that's cool you know I'm saying why
don't we put a paper towel machine on
the side right case you have one of
those crazy days where you got wet hands
and you're standing outside of a van you
know some of the they put on there
we don't need all it is let's put a soap
dispenser on the side of the van
actually that's kind of cool because if
you if you milling around a van a little
bit too much do you can you know the
same wouldn't be surprised if you came
in a little bit dirty
we tried something a little different
this week man I decided to not have you
know usually I got shy Chris Perez in
and that's the you know my Latino
sidekick who's here affiliating and
helping out and I got Cory Cass who does
the editing and I got Budd Galloway who
came to fix the studio up this week and
make it bigger which he did also he
didn't clean up anything and he hid all
the cables so basically took me
two hours to set this up but what
am I gonna do try and be grateful that's
it be happy that at least anybody wants
to come and help out and be a part of
things that's it that's it that's it you
know because I'm not gonna be an alien
to myself I'm not gonna be an alien in
my own life you know when I start
getting just holding too much regret or
too too much judgement that's when I
feel my inner alien Kia you know and
that's what I want to climb up that van
ladder maybe there is a good point you
know when you're just standing outside
of a van and you're just you're like
man I can't take it just you know
being outside of this van anymore
I'll see you later and
then it's just like and you're just on
top of the van
whatever man that's what's been going on
but I met Gerard Butler beautiful to
eye-to-eye-to-eye Jerry
they called him to I Jerry they had a
train hit another train an Amtrak and
I'll say this man that's the risk you
take on the track baby and I hate to say
that you know but that's the risk you
take on the track and I've been on
Amtrak man and they had a dude on there
one time I remember could something was
in his eye socket
he could take he could put a cigarette a
lit cigarette you know in that in
between his eye and them that I meet
that's right under your eye and he could
it inhale it that way and that was wild
and we would watch him do that at night
me and my brother we used to take that
train from Hammond Louisiana all the way
up to Chicago
champaign-urbana and my grandfather
would pick us up up there and and then
he would drive us over to my
grandparents house where we would spend
some time and then and then my
grandparents didn't want me to come
anymore and they just wanted my brother
to come and uh and so but that's life
you know sometimes your grandparents
don't want you you know what are we
gonna do bro we're gonna move onward
that's it but that game is rocking right
now
that game is rocking so I think here's
well here's what I'm thinking my doing I
think I'm gonna check in with the game
real quick you're not gonna notice cuz
I'm gonna be right back and I'm gonna
watch a little bit more when I went on
when I folded out of the game it was
9:00 to 3:00
somebody had missed an extra point and
that was Philadelphia and Philadelphia
is that City of Brotherly Love you know
and it's very much like New Orleans they
got that vibe you know they got a they
got that african-american culture they
got that black vibe they got that you
know the thing real things are happening
people's out on the streets living life
you know they got some good food they
got some gunplay
you know you got a lot of whites hiding
in the distance you know it's similar
similar similar or city work now it
doesn't have Philadelphia is more like
that you know they got that historical
kind of aspect I think Thomas Jefferson
up there who else from Philadelphia
probably damn who else would be from
Philadelphia I don't know man
somebody else other people you know but
it's a wild city and another excited
dude I went to this party one time and
fill it off yet night and it was a bar
but it was like in a house it was pretty
bizarre and they would stop the music
not joking between every song and do the
Eagles fight song whatever it was and
lord knows if somebody did see an eagle
up there in Philadelphia they'd shoot
that down and eat it I mean and
that's I mean I you know I'm amazed at
that's still their mascot you know I'm
sure I'm surprised it's not the TV
dinner you know what I'm saying but they
set up in Philly man they had these
these dudes was like trying to get me to
hook up I wanted our friends you know
this girl and they're like yeah man take
whatever I don't know what her name was
Sheila something or Shayla take home
Shayla you know she's uh she's a real
slam Pig and that I guess meant somebody
was sexually active somebody that's a
slam Pig and I never thought about I
never heard even heard of that you know
somebody being a slam Pig and somebody
being sexually active like that but
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna check
in on that game you're not gonna notice
I'm gonna be right back in just a second
and I'll be able to update on how I felt
so far in the game but so far here's
what I felt I felt like it didn't feel
like the Super Bowl to me this after the
first quarter I'm excited to see Tom
Brady out there that feels exciting I
thought that that long shot that they
that Philadelphia took into the end zone
out the gate that was exciting because
you know you see some of these young
quarterbacks even though foals isn't
brand new but you see these guys get in
there and they get nervous you know and
you see Tom Brady out there and they
just had a video of him kissing his son
you know which i think is fine I think
you don't see enough of that I mean it
might have been a little wild coz tom
was laying down that's the part that
made it wild you know but I think if you
want to kiss your son a little bit this
was a little bit Roman really let's
check out a little bit ancient Rome on
me you know it had that uh tar sherry
and they was looking a little Targaryen
there suddenly when when you know his
son leaned down and kiss him and it
looked a little bit like the father was
in a like Tom Brady had died there was a
lot of things going on there for me when
I saw that video and if you haven't seen
that video it's Tom Brady kisses his son
his son comes over and kisses him and he
said it's not enough he said that's not
enough I want I want that that
championship kiss and look dude if my
dad I'll be honest with you my father
never wanted dude and actually he
borrowed I remember about 70 bucks off
him when he died right before he died
and when you 70 bucks off of a damn 16
year old or 14 year old or whatever
that's I mean hell that was probably 70%
of my retirement you know and he uh and
he borrowed that money off of me and and
look I'm just saying if my like I'm just
saying this if Tom Brady's my dad dude I
would kiss him man I would have kissed
that new bride might even kiss him on
the neck a little bit
not even sexually just like this is
my dad you know just like Russell it's
like you know when you got them hitters
out there there's something different
about them I mean that's like Russell
Crowe if I were him I'd wear sunglasses
because somebody would steal one of that
dudes eyeballs like that's the
thing if I ran up on Russell Crowe man
and I had a piece on me or something
you know I'm a hot man I ain't taking a
damn I ain't taking a his wallet I
pull that piece out put it up by
his dome and say give me that eyeball
you know I'm saying him spit that
into a cup Jerry you know what did
I call him Russell Crowe man Jerry
Butler man Gerard spit that yeah I said
I don't know if your ice I had can spit
something out but spit that eyeball into
a cup Jerry because I'm auctioning this
off the internet and then
fast-forward years later I'm on a train
on an Amtrak and I see a guy on the
corner smoking a cigarette out of his
eye socket empty eye socket and it's
Gerard Butler showing out showing his
new skills because when you're a man
like that I don't think you fade fast I
think some heroes have hero built into
them you know and that reminds me I saw
John Mayer the other night at the Comedy
Store and uh and I know I'm
name-dropping in this episode but it's
just great I got into a conversation
with him we talked for about eight
minutes and I'm not bragging
I'm not whatever you know John
there's a wildcat I mean I'm envious of
probably some parts of his life I'm
certainly mes of his of his brain I'm
envious of his music style probably most
of his life dude is also tall you know
but uh but my here I have a funny story
about John Mayer so this was about let
me see 12 years ago I was working as a
tour manager and that's basically where
you just you carry the guitar and drive
around a musician and it just so
happened that the musician was a friend
of mine this is actually been about 14
years ago and the musician was a friend
of mine his name was Josh Kelly
and so next thing you know you know I'm
driving Josh all around the country and
he hired me as his tour manager because
I was his friend and we had a great
mutual friend anyway so next time you
know on that tour we met John Mayer
because John's music was coming out the
same time as Josh's was they were just
both breaking as artists and uh and then
we met John Mayer and I and a lot of my
friends I was at a party and that's
where I met John Mara and I hadn't I I
had been listening to John Mayer's music
cuz I was listening to all these
breaking artists at the time so I see
him at this party I know who he is a lot
of my friends who were at the party did
not know he wasn't you know he wasn't
the John Mayer that people know about
now you know it's popular and so I was
like and I and I met him there anyway
fast forward 11 12 years I'm at The
Comedy Store one night and John Marin
Jeff Ross are friends and he comes
walking around the corner and I just
like kind of chest to chest with him and
I was like hey John I was like I met you
and before I could finish he goes I met
you on Lafayette Street
he said yeah and that's where I'd met
him at I'd met him about 12 years
earlier on Lafayette Street and here he
just remembered it you know he got that
wild brain some people have that they
got that hero circuit board he could be
an alien now I wouldn't put it past John
Mayer to be an alien and I don't mean
that in like an egg you know negative
alien or something you know I just mean
that as a bit as a basic regular alien
because he I mean the man has a lot of
skills you know I've seen him do
stand-up comedy's pretty you know he
does a good job with that but he just
has that brain you know he has that he's
got that you know he's got that brain
that's on that next level you know he's
like we're all using a push mower and
he's running on a weed whacker he's just
got one of those wild brains and I think
if there were aliens amongst us that's
probably what they would have you know
cuz that would be that would go under
the radar you know you see something out
in the distance you know with four arms
or I mean we are we already shoot things
with antlers
so even if something shows up with an
antler is o'clock you know it's
taking a it's a couple slugs to
the dome you know what I'm saying it's
all of a sudden for every you know buck
or wildebeest out there is you know
every night is Detroit every night is
Detroit or every night is a Chicago or
New Orleans for them for those animals
cuz they could get popped popped all the
time but but anyhow he has that brain he
just remembered you know and then we
talked the other night for a little bit
and it was uh we just talked about like
dating and relationships and that kind
of thing but um but anyhow does a crazy
week man that's just you know and that
was this weekend that was Thursday and
Friday night and and that was this
weekend but i'ma check in on the game
I'll be back in a second you won't
notice and and I'm back Wow so that was
that halftime show that's what I saw up
until and some good offense out there
man if game is looking pretty tight you
know Philadelphia this looks fearless
out there like they don't look like
there's a lot of intimidation you know
that these are the Patriots you can see
the Patriots age a little bit showing I
mean Brady still is I mean the guys six
foot seven hundred you know so he's
throwing from you know it's like
throwing from the second floor of a
building so he had that uh you know that
ability even when he's throwing
downfield it's like he's throwing it's
like he's throwing downhill all day you
know he can throw a 30-yard pass and
it's downhill he you know he just has
that you know he's got that ability you
know and that's what happened when you
when you suck up when you get that
little lip lock from your son you get
that extra ability I bet he got that son
love in him he's got that vibe you know
and and I saw the halftime show and it
was good man I thought it was good I
thought I thought that that Timberlake
just really you know he's like the
closest thing we got to a black guy I
think as white people you know I used to
think it was Michael Rapaport but he's
it's not him it's I think Timberlake's
the closest
when I was young it was Rappaport was
kind of that guy you remember he was in
a lot of um I know he always played the
the the black white guy or the white guy
in the black and a lot of black shows
but Timberlake said you know he's the
closest thing that we got I think he's
close to saying that we got I thought he
did a great job of just entertaining and
I thought he heated up as it went on you
know we started off he seemed a little
bit he looked you know you know he's
seen however old he was and by the time
he got to the end I'm like damn this boy
he might be about 14 now you know he
dude if he keeps Fifi performance for
another five minutes he's gonna end up
back on the Mickey Mouse Club
you know cuz he was just he was running
on a lot of good cylinders there so
that's it man that's all I got really
about that you know the game is still
going on hold on a little bit of our
interim you pop it in the game is still
going on and I'll check back in in a
little bit but Philadelphia was up by I
think eight or ten yeah so let's get
back into it man we're gonna crack into
some of these calls in just a minute but
I wanted to give you guys a state of the
podcast address and that's just
basically kind of like what's going on
with the podcast where we're at and and
what's cracking overall things are going
really good you know I want to say that
a hundred percent you know the
listenership is up we're getting you
know we're up to like a decent number
we'd love to get to try try to get to
you know more subscribers on YouTube but
I wanted to talk to you about some of
the stuff that's kind of going on and
some of the stuff that's gonna be
happening you know and really it's it's
it's just trying to get back to the
simplicity of when the show started and
that's something I wanted to do this
week was just kind of you know just be
here by myself doing it
because that's really what it's all
about and I wanted to thank you guys for
your support and for you know just for
you know a lot of calls a lot of guys
call anyone but some real things that
are going on and and it helps me stay
ground and helps me think about you know
people's lives outside of my own because
that's what I'm the best as a person I
find when I'm not thinking about myself
because you know I have that infection
I have that infection of ego and it's
built into us and that and that
infection makes me think about myself a
lot of times you know I just want to let
you guys know that this is gonna
continue to be a safe place I'm gonna
get back in and checking the voicemails
again so that I know you know exactly
what's called who's calling in and
what's going on that's a buddy of Mines
brother sir my phone's hooked up you
know and we're gonna keep you know you
know a lot of guys were here whenever we
started you know a lot of those OG
though you know Tom from North Carolina
one leg Pat JP animal guy you know he's
gonna be calling back and I was got a
picture he sent me a picture yesterday
of uh of his stepdad he kind of you know
getting into an argument with a um an
alligator a small alligator or a
strong lizard one of the other Rico from
New Hampshire they get you know
everybody Jesse
Jimmy del moro who sent in who sent in a
lot of audio for us to check out anybody
that submitted music Jesse Lucero you
know starlight Stevie who sent that
stuff in last week who sent that hitter
in last week
you know the youtubers Johnson five four
three Johnson five four three anybody
just anybody I'm just saying who people
who have been a part we're gonna keep
you know we want to keep that localized
vibe so that's some of the goal trying
to get to 50,000 subscribers you know we
have some goals in the big picture you
know what out and then to continue to
try to do new stuff you know I had the
the studio is a little bit bigger you
guys can't see it but we're gonna try to
have a guest on and just see how that
feels you know I mean I still get
nervous sometimes just talking to
somebody so to talk to somebody and do
it in front of other people
you know it's baby steps for me some of
this stuff but you know just to try to
continue to do this past Thursday every
week to do a follow up because there's
been some cool stuff you know some cool
some cool some cool men and women out
there calling in with stuff that's going
on in their lives and us being able to
discuss it as a group so I just want to
let you guys know that that's kind of
what's going on and really all that it
is is not
much you know just trying to stick with
the same thing by the end of the year
I'd love to have all my own equipment
you know that we own and I want to thank
everybody on patreon who helps out and
supports there you know that money I
mean you know as soon as this frickin
lens comes in because some who
were selling lenses out there aren't
doing on the up-and-up because I've
gotten you know I've ordered these
lenses and them and come in so we can't
activate the second camera yet but you
know it's trial and error and I want to
thank grey block pizza cuz they've been
there you know and they've been
supportive all year and and I'm just
really grateful because it's things like
that that are helping us and by the end
of the year maybe being a studio being
an in actual you know an on-site
location an on-site location somewhere
where we can do some real gang gang
types type stuff you know 420 Gucci gang
all day so you know that so that's some
things that are going on and that's just
the state of the podcast address and
really it's just a thank you for you
guys as support thank you gray block
thank you everybody here we go so let's
get into a man you know uh I already
told you guys what happened this past
weekend man ran across a lot of
straight-up superstars who could be
aliens who had that ability you know
like what if somebody came what if
something you know you got a message one
day in your inbox and it said that you
were an alien could you handle it
seriously man some of y'all are like
what the Theo talking about I'll
tell you what the I'm talking about
dude I'm talking about real I'm
talking about things that could be
possible man you don't think I mean look
at us we're in space bro Z and chick and
ladies we're in space you don't think
somebody out here could be milling
around as a alien walking around
at night by themselves drinking
gasoline and chocolate milk and probably
you know they could probably do crazy
stuff hide inside their own ass who
knows I've seen crazier man you
know I've seen crazy
I've did unto a blind kid that could
jump high and I used to fight
him and so until you've been through
like that you know you you know
when you go to stuff like that you start
to believe what's possible out there you
go fight a blind kid that could jump
high dude he's got the aggression of a
dim of a Wolverine and that's a bull and
a Wolverine you ass and I'm sorry to get
heated man but but I think the one thing
that if we did have aliens now they
would admit it they would say I'm an
alien aliens in the past know there
would be hunt people would hunt them
pitchfork um you know people I mean
some people can't even you know
talk to somebody who drinks Pepsi if
they're a coke drinker so you know 20
years ago people couldn't handle
somebody you know slipping him off to
the side and saying guess what daddy's
on that alien tip you know you know
daddy's out there at night
snorting Stardust dude and eatin
pieces of glass in the garage you know
because it you know because the the
Orban distance says he has to we
couldn't handle it but now if an alien
were here I think not only will we
handle it you know he'd be like I mean
he would just probably he'd be like the
rock he'd be like Dwayne the rock
Johnson but he would have you know he'd
have millions of Twitter followers and
Instagram followers and everything he
would just have fans now and if you were
if he was an alien now he would admit it
he'd be like look I'm an alien you know
so give me all the free I'm awesome
you know but let's get into the rest of
the podcast ma'am let's get into the
rest of it we had Mickey callin do so
many great calls came in from my boy
Mickey sweet Mickey boy and Mickey's out
there running down his lungs are rundown
and so we're gonna listen a little bit
of Mickey right here take a hit off of
Mickey hey yo see oh man this is Mickey
calling from Seattle so here's my
situation man I'm 30 years old and I'm
currently at the end stage of a lung
disease now my current lungs don't have
very long left by about two and a half
years hopefully we can stretch them out
so like right you know and this came in
this came in on Thursdays episode I'm
just playing it against it was case
something you guys didn't hear it Mickey
got them empty hitters man you ever had
a gallon of milk and it gets to the end
and you're shaking it like that just see
how much milk is still in there and
that's where Mickey's at you know
almond the silver lining is that I'm
gonna be soon on the lung transplant
list I'm open I'm gonna get listed which
will give me a few more years to figure
this whole thing out that's what I'm
saying so Mickey's trying to get that
time and I texted with Mickey the other
day you know and he said he appreciated
you know how he discussed it last week
on the cast and that we had a good time
and we you know we just talked openly
about what's going on you know about
what's going on with his life and he's
on that you know that he's running light
on air because we've all been somewhere
we've all been running a little bit
light on something you know but Mickey's
got them tickin he's got them tickers in
him and those things are just ticked
talking and the whole time and so he's
hoping to get on that transplant list
and I know that that's a special moment
man when that happened that you get on
that list and you have that you know you
have that hope and we're certainly gonna
wish that for you and I even text to
make I said look man we'll try to find
you a along through the podcast you know
because I've been some callers out there
my boy JP JP down in Alabama
he's only have one leg so he probably
wouldn't you know not I'm not putting
words in his mouth you know but he
probably wouldn't mind you know coming
in on you know one you
know err tit you know what I'm saying
that long let's hear a little more
Mickey and it's been a really difficult
time and I've been single through it my
question to you man is during this
difficult time that's really ruined my
confidence I wanted to ask you and the
viewers what they think what are some
good steps that I can take to start
boosting my confidence and my self-worth
there you go man and you know what this
makes me think man honestly is that it's
just it's so wild that that we are in a
time
men are struggling so much with their
self-confidence and self-worth that even
that even it's like no matter what is
going on I mean here is Mickey with a
real ailment you know I mean this is
something that is probably very rare you
know I remember when my sister needed a
liver it was I mean one in like a
million children was born with the issue
that she had and I don't even know what
Mickey did you know I don't know some
people blow through their own stuff you
know me you might I mean if he's out
there huffing gas or something
or doing that kind of and blowing
through his lungs then that's different
but if this is something that you know
that came into him by nature then that's
you know then that's that's another
different you know and that's more real
but you know here you are you know you
have this you have this thing going on
man and you are you're dealing with the
same stuff still you know it's just wild
it's wild that you know that it's like
no matter who we are that sometimes
there's so many problems that are you
know that that just connect us all I
mean you could have somebody out there
with no head or no and no arms and legs
and they you know they would they would
still be worrying about self confidence
you know and these sorts of things man
and it just I don't know how it made it
makes me feel man it makes me feel I
guess a little bit I don't know if I
want to say not ungrateful but it makes
me feel a little disappointed maybe in
myself you know that Here I am and I'm
hell you know I'm healthier than Mickey
is right now and that I'm you know maybe
I'm not taking that all the steps I
could take all the time to try and boost
my own self confidence and stuff like
that
even though I know it's not one of those
things it's you know that's always
easily fixable but you know it's like
here I am just you know Here I am I
don't have a ticking time you know I
don't have - you know - ticking time
bombs in my body you know I'm not on
that on the clock and and so since
that's the case I'm
worried about as much about you know
always getting myself to wellness
whereas here's Mickey's out there he's
on the clock and the one of the things
he wants to do he must a man up in case
he doesn't see in case he doesn't have
the opportunity to stick around he wants
to defeat that self-confidence you know
and you know man it's just I can't
imagine what you've been through but
some of our listeners have some thoughts
bring some suggestions and we're gonna
crack in a little bit that right now
here we go Mickey yeah the tricky dicky
from Pittsburgh and this is Ricky Dicky
from Pittsburgh and I've never even I
don't know I guess that's your real name
I'm not even sure brother I've never I
don't think I ever called anybody Ricky
Dicky onward I'm calling in to talk
about a more Mickey and the lungs and I
think I think his best bet might be to
find someone with you know another
ailment someone that needs a kidney or a
liver or they need lungs and they could
breathe life into each other no pun
intended
well I mean it seems like obvious pun
intended right there but but you know
what man you might be right you know it
is funny how we we you if you if you
have somebody that has some of the same
issues that it brings you together and
that's one thing that sharing issues
does and we're able to share like what
is what is what makes us hurt you know
when you're able to share that with
somebody it's crazy how it brings you
together you know I've noticed that in
brief moments with dating and stuff like
that when I'm actually able to try and
voice what is going on what scares me
that it ends up instead of thinking
I'm gonna say this and this person is
gonna hate me or this person is not
gonna care about me anymore
instead it just makes them understand me
and so much care usually comes out of
understanding that it's fascinating so
you may be onto something there you know
that you that you know sometimes you can
see that you can see
which you know the feeling of and you
see it in somebody else and if you're
able to be a good partner for that
person because you can understand them
the best because you're saddling up on
that film those feelings and riding that
similar vibe whatever it is every day
now if you're talking about just mix and
match in people that's Frankensteinian
you know I'm saying if you're talking
about finding somebody with a one leg
and some of the different leg and
matching them up then that's wild you
know that's you know I mean that's just
I mean it makes sense if you're charting
if you're you know doing it drawing and
if you're trying to Pete you know if
you're if you're doing a human puzzle a
puzzle made out of humans but it doesn't
make sense
realistically I don't think you know but
but I don't know if you had somebody
that you know their heart didn't work
and yet somebody's brain didn't work and
you put them together could make beauty
but that's Ricky Dicky out of Pittsburgh
man making us a little bit of some
suggestions from Mickey and and also I
know I'm gonna be in Tacoma and I you
know I'm gonna be in Tacoma and I'm
announcing it right now the 15th and
16th that's Thursday and Friday and
that's outside of Seattle and Tacoma and
we're gonna try to get a date for Mickey
because you know in the rest of his call
if you listen last week he talks about
he wants to have more confidence you
know he'd like to meet he'd like to you
know fall in love you know we'd like to
meet a lady and he wasn't talking about
sex he wasn't talking about you know you
know just reaching down into some moist
you know touching that moist he was
talking about being out there and maybe
looking for some love you know look he
was out there trying to get up in that
you know that baritone maker in between
that in between those ribs and that's
the heart so just a lot going on in this
man let's listen to another call that
came in right here but we're gonna try
to set Mickey up there and in Tacoma so
if you have somebody out there in Tacoma
who's a lady you know you know and she's
got you know I'm saying she don't mind a
little guy who's you know maybe who
might you don't have to take a early
break during sex you know then maybe you
could set you know you know set us up
and
my boy Mickey out there unless you know
maybe him ago and me and him and I'll
bring a lady or something we'll take
some ladies out on a double date or
something
or we'll just set them up and let him
and this girl go out there and have a
good time you know but uh but no matter
what Mickey's gonna be my guests there
up there and Tacoma man and I'm looking
forward to it we texted about it he said
he's gonna keep his schedule open
let's hear some other calls you guys had
for him here we go the other two chicken
calling from California in regards to
God who's waiting for a lung transplant
yeah that guy's Mickey brother okay
thanks for calling Jason on word he's
asking how he could be more confident
there's absolutely totally a way that
you can be confident just as much as the
rest of us because I think at the end of
the day that person who has the most
integrity who is the most true to their
soul that is like the most real man that
you can be and if you're ever in the
presence of a person who is
authentically empowered with no guilt
with total integrity the total devotions
are just doing the right thing for all
who are involved there is a sense of
energy that person carries that even a
very large confident bodybuilder would
have to kind of recognize that wow wow
man I think you might have just put
every buddy on blast right there like in
our hearts you know I mean that's that's
correct I mean that was a I mean that's
a real that was awesome Jason I
appreciate that
let's listen to the end of this and then
oh and lack of confidence I would start
to really build up personal integrity
start helping people so I'm making
people feel better start being the one
person who is brave enough to be nice
and do the righteous thing especially if
you own that could be you yeah Wow I
don't even what to say really I mean
that's you know that's why I'm the
middleman here because I don't know I
you know I don't have that I don't have
those words inside of me like that man
did right there but if for some reason
when he said that I know that that that
that that's the truth when you have that
when you are the truest man it's like
you surf in your own
it's like surfing your own it's like
surfing on your own semen bro and I
don't mean to be crass but I bet that's
how it feels when you are guilt free and
you are living and you are living in the
place where you were you're where you
where you are just gonna be righteous
you're gonna try your best you know now
the problem is when you do that it's
just that's when that ego that ego
starts taking hits off of your righteous
after you doing the right things and
starts telling it oh I do the right
things you know and that's where the ego
comes in but man I live clean and free
like that and maybe I'm talking because
I've never done that you know I mean
I've never lived completely you know out
of debt emotionally or out of debt
spiritually you know I'm in spiritual
debt you know anonymize I'm not coming
at you into like a religious or anything
but I just know in my heart that uh you
know that there's you know I got a
couple Outsiders living in my heart you
know I'm saying but I know that that's
the right answer that if you build up
that integrity man you build up that 100
percent that people can smell that on
you let's uh thank you for that call
let's take one more here we go Oh what's
good bro this is Pennsylvania Pete
Pennsylvania Pete I've never called
anybody that let's hear more I'm calling
in response to your boy trick alone
Mickey TLM baby and if you want to see
the call for specifically from Mickey
UNAM and my thoughts on it that's on
youtubes out there homework not in his
personal situation so I can't say how it
would be to overcome you know the fear
of death in such a short time span and
then how to talk to women but I feel
like you know the best bet for him to do
would be to accept it as quick as he can
start joking about it right and what you
start joking about it you know I don't
know if you'll ever be able to really
accept it because I think that's the
thing that everyone you know has
troubles dealing with you know this is
the fear of Diane's so so scary but yeah
the best thing maybe cuz you
you know come to terms of it and then
well I mean look I think Mickey's
called-up confident his dude
you know Pennsylvania Pete and I will
call you that now I think Mickey called
up 100 about his activity you know I
mean this guy's out I mean you know he's
being brave he could just lay on the
internet and jerk off dude you know and
get exhausted quick and just you know
get rest a little and then jerk off
again but he's not doing that you know
he's saying he wants to he wants more he
wants more then his present Long's can
hold you know what I'm saying he wants
to double down on his own life that's
what he wants to do he's willing to take
that risk
he's asking the universe I want love
because I'm gonna get on that transplant
list I'm gonna get that second I'm gonna
get four lungs tricky Mickey's
gonna be a damn amphibian come 2022 that
boys gonna be out there
backstroking in your lake and banging
your sister and stepmom at the same time
so fricken you know I mean Pennsylvania
Pete accepted and I mean like I feel you
it sounds like he's accepted it though
it sounds like he's accepted it you know
maybe you got to accept big PD maybe you
got to accept maybe you sitting around
your room looking you got three or four
sisters or siblings in the house female
siblings you know and you thinking oh
damn maybe you're scared that somebody
with as much integrity as sweet Mickey
has out there now when he gets us
sucrose tup with them new air bags then
he's gonna come to your house and he's
gonna give you a bunch of nieces and
nephews you know cuz that is a lover boy
so you might be living in fear Pete
anyway I don't mean to get fired up
though I do appreciate everybody's call
and I always do let's take one more
let's hit let's hit another call here
man here we go what's up Bo this is PJ
I'm calling about that uh Mickey was
running on them human on the load tanks
okay yeah I figure TJ thanks for calling
dude you honestly sound like you have
less time to be alive a minute Mickey
brother be honest with you uh no shame
no shame you know and in looking Mickey
and I texted at the other day about
joking around and he was cool man he
said it was you know he laughed and he'd
been having a laugh and he'd been
sharing this experience with his friends
and uh and look that's why I'm from so
sometimes if somebody's like man you
joke about that's too real well
guess what you know I didn't choose that
for myself always and I do know that it
is a problem that I have sometimes I do
joke when things shouldn't be joked
about you know but I mean I grew up man
my dad was 70 when I was born you know
that my sister would had a liver was on
that it was not on the liver list you
know I mean she laid in the crib dude
she was green and yellow in different
colors for five six years you know had
so many scars on her body look like a
damn you know look like uh I mean look
like a scarecrow
look like the child of a scarecrow you
know so my first thoughts growing up
where is that everybody's dying you know
what am I trying to glom anybody out but
I'm trying to let you know where some of
my sense of humor comes from you know so
you don't think I'm just out here that's
where my sense of humor got made that if
I didn't have if I wasn't able to find
some joy in that you know and going up
to my dad and not knowing each time if
he's alive or just you know resting he'd
have friends come over both of them fall
asleep on the couch and I'm thinking we
got a carbon monoxide leak in the house
but the truth is both are more just in
their late 70s and they just we're
having a conversation and one of them
didn't talk for a little bit and both of
them dozed off but TJ man you sound like
you might need a spare long but let's
hear more thank you for calling TJ you
know my best place would be maybe if she
can go on one of these dating sites
his online dating sites you need to kind
of explain it such a waste in like so
you know whoever knows his situation
right off the bat because worst thing
you can do is get you know attached a
girl really serious with her you know
and she wants to spend the rest of her
life with you in Internet you know two
years down the road on your day oh I
hope that doesn't happen you know saying
but I think that would be the best thing
it just explained the situation going
through a hard time more some
companionship yeah yeah I mean anyway
that's my advice let me park as well
Thank You TJ man and I and I love you
bud I'm sorry I've been a little fired
up this episode you know but uh but new
you know and and look here's the thing
TJ brings up a good point because look
Mickey I'll tell you this brother we're
all on dating apps everybody's out there
on them you know so that's not like you
know I don't want you to think that and
look man I'm not trying I mean I can't
imagine the you know what you're having
to deal with Mickey you know here you
are sharing something that's that's I
mean that's the realest thing you know
somebody turns on the egg timer that
that you know turns an egg timer on on
inside of your body you know and here
you are sharing that with us and letting
us talk about that and think about that
you know and even joke about it
and so I want to say thank you for
letting us do that but but but the thing
is also I don't want you to think you're
missing out on some magical universe
where you know air capable people you
know people that are fully air capable
or you know out here just dating and you
know and everything is easy-peasy part
of the problem is things have changed
now and so we're all out here all these
electronics we're all kind of becoming
alien to each other you know speaking of
aliens we're all we're all kind of
becoming alien to each other so you know
it is tough it's tough idea for a lot of
people but you know I'll say this meant
a lot women and and this is might be a
weird way to look at it but women love a
project
women love a man they can rescue women
love you know and women also this is a
dark way to put it kind of a women love
death and murder and stuff every
woman I know has seen every episode of
Dateline ever I mean I secretly think
that women want to get murdered and I
don't mean that in like a you know a
me-too or any of that times up time not
talking about anything like that but I
think that women secretly have this
fascination with you know getting almost
murdered let's say that because they're
all watching it all the time and so you
know I'm saying you have that mysterious
element if I want to be mysterious I
gotta put on like a um you know
a dark bonnet or get a hammer or
something but if you want to be
mysterious Mickey you just roll up you
know what I'm saying you're freaking
lungs I mean they you know roll up with
a picture of your lungs show her
that picture like dead look baby girl
these things a couple of a cups right
here I'm running on you know a couple of
bat wings left in your bully so
why don't you and me you know why don't
we see at least uh how uh how deep my
heart is I mean you got a pick up you
can make a pickup line that could be
deeper than anything like hey honey my
lungs don't work someone I have to smell
you with my heart you know so I'm gonna
have to hold your scent in my heart and
that's that third Longman that heart you
know that's that long that holds uh that
holds a you know that holds you know the
air that that holds that arm or most
important air and you sound like you got
a big one of those but man it you know I
you just have any thinkin all week man
you've had me thinking and I appreciate
it Mickey and I look forward to seeing
it
, and if you guys have somebody you
think it'll be good a setup for Micky
email me you know and that's just th EO
v o NK @ ma c-calm and they got to live
up in Tacoma Seattle don't send me
somebody from Indiana we busing
in some Muppet from Indiana you know
what I'm saying some chick that's just
you know just got out the system or
something or some brought out them
halfway houses we're not doing all of
that you know this ain't a
you know we ain't trying to you know
bring somebody's clout up I mean trying
to Greyhound some out from
Evansville and I'm saying we're talking
about let's find him a decent woman who
may be interested in a man that is a man
he ain't coming in light in any in any
loafers he's coming in heavy in the
heart and maybe a little lighting along
alright guys let's take this call right
here here we go this was a separate call
that came in hey what's going on then
love this oh this is Cooper I'm
wondering if you can maybe help me out
with a personal problem you know all
right Cooper thank you for calling
homeward go just speaking from your life
experience have you ever been dating a
you know a real fiery spicy latina maybe
a Caribbean girl like a real exotic girl
she maybe she's got like a like a pet
parrot at home I'm just wondering how do
you deal with the bird when a tackle on
you during sex
alright so I think that's obviously a
you know joking around this coop Cooper
sorry
calling about a bird so that's Iran
Iranian II Cooper bird coop and I'll say
this dude a Latino spicy latina or
Caribbean woman okay probably different
things dude go down to the Caribbean bro
I'd love to see you go down there sweet
coop let me tell you what happened to me
one time down in the Caribbean or in
Jamaica or somewhere okay I go when to a
Starbucks do that a sign outside says
Starbucks I'll walk in there's a lady
back in there looks
weird in there there's a lady she's like
welcome to the star buckle lounge
can I get jaws smoothie it wouldn't even
a Starbucks dude somebody's stolen a
Starbucks on put it up outside of a
smoothie center some I don't
know what the it was dude
and then I order a gave the lady some
money she went out the back wrap
never saw it waited 20 minutes went out
in the street and there was a about a
block away there was literally a knife
fight right in front of me two dudes
fighting with knives which very fun to
watch watchin dudes fight with knives
bright is damn I mean it's you know it's
that killer capoeira right there
you know and it was pretty fun and then
when I'm chasing yellowing down the
street but I like to see you out there
doing all of that Mister coop and I yeah
but I'll be and also I made love to a
girl in Denver years ago this blonde
girl and she lived at a high altitude
and she had a gray parrot lit and a lot
of parrot let's I believe her from South
America and it would actually be on my
shoulder once in a while we were making
love but that's not that's not hard to
be because I'm not good at making love
so you know easy place for a bird to
roost but anyhow alright let's get this
one last call in and I want to let you
guys know some dates that I'm gonna be
performing I will be in Portland Oregon
and that is this weekend at Harvey's
comedy club and you can find that
tickets to that on Theo von comm slash
tour tou R as well next weekend on be in
La Jolla at the Comedy Store after that
the 23rd and 24th of February and
fantasy Springs Casino and then the 15th
and 16th I'll be in Tacoma they're in
Washington the 17th I'll be in Spokane
and those are of March March 15th
through 17th March 23rd and twenty
through 25th I'll be in Oxnard
California at levity live and then in
April
I'll be at bananas comedy and that's in
New Jersey somewhere I'm not sure where
and then also
I got this little announcement I guess
it's an announcement I'm gonna be
shooting a movie a film it's a small
it's a million dollar budget and I'm
gonna be shooting with Thomas Ian
Nicholas in' let me see Thomas Ian
Nicholas sorry Thomas Ian Nicholas and
you can check him out and you'll
remember him from a lot of a lot of
films he was in that movie where they
the they have the picture that breaks
that breaks his arm and then he he
throws the arm in from the outfield and
he throws it really fast and he gets a
job working for the Los Angeles Dodgers
so I'm gonna be shooting a movie with
him
called Bitcoin and yeah Thomas Ian
Nicholas and I went to his film premiere
the other night it was really really
great
super nice guy and I'm looking forward
to that and he is the same age as me and
we'll be shooting that in Albuquerque in
May so that's pretty cool man I'm
excited about that opportunity to work
with him you know he was in that movie
and I can't remember the name that he's
been he's been in so many films and I'm
not trying to pigeonhole him he was also
an American Pie and the American Pie
series but I don't watch a ton of films
and that's what I remember him from but
so yeah it should be cool you know
should be cool to do that I'm looking
forward to it
now with movies in Hollywood you know
don't always come to fruition but
as of right now it's all contracted out
and we are ready to rock so looking
forward to that all right man let's take
one more call here and this is a good
this call I already know what it's about
and and I just want to get some advice
uh let's see what he says here we go
homeward hey Theo this is James from
Omaha Nebraska
and I'm calling because I've got a
little bit of Dark Arts on my mind and I
appreciate you calling James and I've
been in Omaha
dude enough honestly masturbated outside
of that city a couple times and and I've
actually and I'll do an update real
quick I've been struggling still with
the adult masturbation touching myself
not others and it's been
you know I'd been doing well and then
last night I fell off you know I fell
off that jerk wagon but I'm trying to
get back on and I'm not giving up and I
just wanted to update and kind of come
clean about that you know and be out
here where I am you know but I
appreciate you calling in here James
with your dark arts issue here we go
onward so I'm 21 years old I have a
girlfriend who I've been dating for
about three years now
oh wow so that's that young love and
that's beautiful man if you're in young
love sometimes it's almost that's the
love that's dangerous people get
murdered at that age and love you know
oh we're it's a pretty serious
relationship I just see myself being
with her the rest of my life by Wow and
you know what good for you man because
that's brave dude you know that's
bravery bro long word but you know
there's this thing on my mind where you
see I lost my virginity to her I've
never been sexually with another woman
before okay so you so uh so this is your
lady that's your girl and y'all that's
called a golden things called a golden
Oreo when you've only had sex with one
person and y'all are gonna and Yeller
and you guys are together you know and
you guys are gonna when you're married
to someone you only had sex with one
person I'm pretty sure it's called a
golden Oreo onward uh the same is not
the it's not the same for her she did
not lose her virginity to me if she
hooked up with several guys before she
met me yeah okay so she's a little bit
more of a Nutter Butter you know and
that's okay man that's okay
um word and so basically you know I I
don't know how I feel about potentially
spending the rest of my life with this
woman and you know not ever not ever
having sex with anybody else part of me
thinks I should be okay with this you
know that perfect one a no record is
probably something a lot of guys wish
they had but for me it's just like man
there's so much out there sexually some
of these sexual experiences that I feel
like man I might be missing out on yep
missing out on you know and that's the
end of the call wow that's a big that's
a big issue big question not an issue
sorry
that's a big question it's a big call
James and I appreciate you calling you
know that I was in your position when I
was young man when I went off to college
I was dating a girl and she'd and I'd
lost my virginity to her outside of a
bowling alley actually you know people
were throwing rocks at us and all kinds
of and it was a different time back
then and it was more of a rural time you
know there's more gravel but you know
and I was jealous and I couldn't get
over the jealousy and it really had
nothing to do with her that just had to
do with me you know and here's the thing
yeah you can get out there and
experience more dating more sexual
Necedah man that is out there that's out
there for you if you want it but there's
something nice if you love someone that
is hard to find again it's hard to find
you know and I believe that I believe
that that is hard to find you can't just
always fall in love you can date
somebody and make a relationship but you
can't always fall in love like that's
really the tough thing so I think you
have to look at what you have is the
grass greener out there I don't know and
only you know that for yourself if
you're honest with your girl you could
say look I feel like I need to explore
more things you know you could tell her
that I and I I know I just I'm not ready
I want to sow my oats a little bit you
don't have to phrase it like that so
it's sexual but you could tell her that
you could let her know
because if you just if you just were to
cut ties with her then that's tricky
you know then she's not gonna know why
should I can know what's going on and
getting earnest whether is really where
you're gonna be able to prosper even
though it's gonna be the tough part I
want to listen you're called one more
time the end the second half of it here
we go before the same is not the it's
not the same for her she did not lose
her virginity to me if she hooked up
with several guys before she met me and
so basically you know I I don't know how
I feel about potentially spending the
rest of my life with this woman and you
know not ever not ever having sex with
anybody else part of me thinks I should
be okay with this you know that perfect
one in the record is probably something
a lot of guys wish they had had but for
me it's just like man there's so much
out there sexually some of these sexual
experiences that I feel like man I might
be missing out on right okay and there
you go man and so I just wanted to hear
it again because I am I'm sometimes I'm
kind of ignorant you know and I got to
hear it again if yeah that one of no
record is good look man there's
something beautiful about about that
bliss man about that ignorant is and
it's not ignorant but this is the sexual
ignorance is because here's the thing
you get out there you start comparing
you start contrasting now I hope you're
not control you're comparing things to
pornography if you're doing that you got
to hold that line bucko because the
things that happen in pornography are
not happening in regular people's sexual
activity you know you get to you see
pornography and it's you know it you
know you know it's all that action and
they got elbows and titties and you know
people with you know freelance buttholes
and all kinds of activity but in real
life dude it's awkward and you
know if somebody just had dinner and
they had capers and they got a belch and
it's you know yet a Pepsi and
there's dog in the corner of the
room and you know it you know there's a
lot of other this is the reality you
know this one's a tough one for me man
so I'm gonna put this one out to our
callers and I'll chime in on this one
next week because that's a real deal you
know that is a real deal when you're out
there and you know I had a girl that I
was in love with in high school and you
know when I lost my virginity to her I
lost my virginity behind you know a
bowling alley standing up and people are
throwing rocks and all kinds of at
us very Gaza Strip if you will and and
but I remember being jealous that the
that this woman had had more partners
than I had but it didn't have anything
to do with her that was all on me so the
jealousy if you have jealousy it's your
thing now how do you handle that and
deal with that at your age who knows you
know I don't know I didn't handle it
well I was angry at her I resented her
but I had no tools for solving any
emotional or relationship problems I had
zero tools
I was flight-or-fight or I think
maybe it might be the third one or just
just fiddle and I would just kind of
fiddle with my fingers then just be you
know kind of loitering and be awkward
and and I also hid outside of a
girl's place one time and petted a cat
out there in South Carolina doing some
lights talking you know and I will
apologize for that but but let's put
that one out to the callers man we'll
put that one out to the callers if you
have some suggestions for James nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three that is the hotline I want to
thank everybody that's been a part of
the podcast has been helping we got we
have we do have exciting stuff happening
for the next year things are slowly
going on and I'm just grateful to be
here with you guys I'm gonna go watch
the end of the Super Bowl you know I was
gonna watch and come back and talk to
you guys again but you know I feel like
we've had a good episode of been a lot
of information you know you know I feel
like maybe you know and it kind of
coming full circle about aliens I feel
like maybe we're becoming aliens you
know maybe we're becoming aliens and I
think that's why part of me wants to
tell
just to stay in there and and and work
it out with your lady that's why part of
me wants to say you know like let's find
so let's find a couple of options or
let's find a girl at least a date for uh
from my boy Mickey you know because man
we're letting love go we're giving up on
it easy you know we're giving up on it
easy and it's not a fair it's not fair
for me to tell you that James really
because I haven't done that in my life
but it doesn't mean always that because
I haven't it doesn't mean that I can't
now you know cuz it's tough I know it's
tough for a lot of men out there you
know to stay in love and then commit to
love but damn maybe that's our battle
these days because we're becoming it we
are we are becoming aliens and alien to
the things that make us human connection
and I feel that I'm not accusing anybody
of it I mean I am I am I am I am guilty
as guilty as the rest man we out there
in these emotions and we out there in
these love streets but we're not alone
bro a gang gang you feel me
alright man I'll see you guys in
Portland this week I'll have an episode
up ooh Thursday I'm going out of town
I'll have an episode up Thursday we'll
follow up and put these calls out to
James and and you guys be good to
yourselves you know what I'm saying you
know you probably deserve it and if you
don't we'll start start asking ourselves
how can I deserve more and how can I
have a little bit more integrity because
that's something that we can all gain
and thank you guys for the calls thank
everybody you guys be good to yourselves
man I'll talk to you soon
[Music]
celebrate
celebrate dog day
Oh
demons
[Music]